[Music]
mexican pot dealers have been using a
marijuana cannon to shoot bricks of pot
across the border in the california yeah
yeah well they they they caught them
they grabbed the pot cannon yeah big
police the Mexican police confiscated it
and turns out Mexican police are big
fans of mine I've known that for a while
and they said Conan will lend you the
pot cannon if you want to use it on your
show true story so guess what it's
parked right now right outside our
studio at this second
[Music]
it's impressive it shoots up to 30
pounds of pot in a single round and our
crew is loading bricks of marijuana into
the cannon as I speak now you're
probably wondering why why they loading
pot into the cannon yeah okay where
would our crew find weed
no I wasn't wondering that at all oh I
sure was hell Edie doesn't get out alive
I figured we want to use the pot cannon
right I figured the best way to use the
pot cannon was to fire bricks of
marijuana into the mouths of celebrity
stoners right wouldn't that be a good
idea yeah so here we go let's go out
there live in our first target is
self-proclaimed pothead there he is Seth
Rogen and I'm told they're ready to fire
and we're gonna go and let's see three
two one
[Music]
I should warn kids about using marijuana
or you could rip your head oh right
let's see that from Seth Rogen's
perspective I'm curious I think we had a
GoPro on him and oh it was nasty all
right let's set up our second target
here she is celebrity stoner Miley Cyrus
there's her new look to one again
I do
let's see that in slow mo I'm just
curious that was your voice load or it's
what that devil we did to Miley you're
an idiot
last target is the ultimate celebrity
stoner whoa check it out there is
spongebob it's our last chance to
that tell you the part canning